kloten hat vor einigen tagen ein video
hochgeladen in dem er auf seine
beliebtesten videos reagiert hat und
eines davon war dieses hier
und der zweite in den kerker mit dir
dieses spiel ganz lustig außer habe ich
mir gedacht stützen wir uns einfach mal
selbst in dieses abenteuer also mörder
wir sehen hier press base to charge step
at the right time der sinn des spiels
ist also dass wir einen stab zur
richtigen zeit in den könig stecken und
quasi den könig töten
ich würde sagen ich stehe jetzt einfach
mal space und jetzt sehen wir dass diese
personen das sind denke ich wir und das
hier ist der könig
wir müssen den könig aus irgendeinem
grund töten schönes bild hier übrigens
gerade das heißt ich würde sagen ich
drucken jetzt einfach mal space
[Musik]
sorry aber das hat überhaupt keinen sinn
ergeben ich habe gerade space gedrückt
und es kam noch ein balken der sich
aufgeladen hat ich drücke jetzt direkt
einfach mal space und halte es auch
gedrückt meine damen und herren das
heißt er dreht sich nicht um und band
ich bin der könig und kann habe ich
wow
ein anderer von hinten oder was ich kann
jetzt einfach space rück und mich um
drinnen
muss sich dieses spiel verstehen also
wir sind eine gewisse person dar
[Musik]
was will was soll ich tun
war das
wieso kommen dann immer andere leute
also diese person das habe ich ja vorhin
schon mitgekriegt der will mich nur an
stupst und mir ein glas rotwein geben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
man vergisst
jetzt ist diese person also der könig
wir sind allerdings immer noch der
charakter das heißt ich warte jetzt erst
mal bissig der jetzige könig umdreht
genau und jetzt halte ich ganz schnell
space gedrückt er lädt das messer aus er
freut sich schon meine damen und herren
und jetzt machen wir bahn
ich bin könig bei dem hier müssen wir
uns jetzt umdrehen
das heißt er wird jetzt von den wachen
abgeführt er wird unten in das verlies
gesteckte jetzt kommt die nächste person
ich weiß nicht ob der vergiftet ist oder
nicht ich würde mal sagen nein also er
bekommt jetzt den wein
[Musik]
das ist sache nicht wahr degas wir
erhalten hier wieder die leertaste
gedrückt bis zu dem moment wo er das
erste rein steckt das heißt stirbt man
eigentlich direkt wenn man messer in den
rücken bekommen zumal selber nachdenken
aber dann dumme fragen die jetzt wieder
die nächste person mit seinem komischen
ball da vorne das heißt ich drehe mich
jetzt um genau er wird von den wachen
abgeführt wird ins verlies gesteckt und
die jetzt traue ich dem typen nicht mit
seinem schuss rotwein
du bist auch im scheiß verließ jetzt bei
diesem typen da bin ich mir nicht sicher
weil er halt auch so ein scheiß messer
irgendwie in der hand hält also er wird
auch nach unten geschleudert diese
person wollte uns darauf haben wir noch
gar nicht ausgeführt was da passiert
[Musik]
was was
das war's
wenn ich mir was ich denke es wird das
wasser ziehen
das war es jetzt hier vom video hier
können jetzt jemanden kanal abonnieren
oder hier unten mal einen schock aus
schenkungen jetzt findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnent zeit
könnt ihr auf die glocke klicken dann
bekommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]